[Music]  the past isn't it  james fate draws us back together  now your enemy is my enemy  his name is seven and what does he want  revenge me when our secret finds its way  out  it'll be the death of you  you can imagine why i've come back to  play  there's a young lady in santiago i want  you to meet you're late  when you're ready  she's a disarming young woman i get why  you shot him  yeah well everyone tries at least once  james bond  we both eradicate people  to make the world a better place i just  want to be a little  tidier  [Applause]  come on bond where the hell are you  harder to tell the good from bad  villains from heroes these days  he's going to kill millions  if we don't do this  there will be nothing left to say  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you